je veux quand même rappeler que vous
avez ouvert beaucoup de crédit j'ai eu
l'occasion de le dire à plusieurs
reprises dans les projets de loi de
règlement c'est près de 30 milliards
d'euros d'excédent qui n'avaient pas été
ouvertes dont d'ailleurs vous avez
utilisé pour financer la dette à hauteur
de 20 milliards donc un moment donné on
est dans une opération de transparence
le parlement est là pour contrôler
l'action du gouvernement faites nous
confiance vous faites aujourd'hui des
annonces moi j'entends mais comme bien
des réserves de crédit et bien que
chacun assume enfin on peut pas demander
de la sobriété de la rigueur budgétaire
et essayer de contourner une fois de
plus la fonction du parlement qui est
aussi d'exercer son contrôle
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]